before I get to tonight's opponent I'm
going to take a trip down memory lane I
don't want to I hate lanes too quaint
but I'm going to do this you all
remember the supposed blue wave of
democratic wins on November 7th and the
grandstanding leftist narrative
surrounding one winner in particular
Danika Rome Danika Rome
Danika Rome the first openly transgender
person ever to be elected to a US State
House Rome defeated Robert Marshall a 13
turn incumbent who had introduced an
anti trans bathroom bill so she
triumphed over the trans foam and now
she's surfing the big blue wave the MSM
claims it's crashing onto the
Republicans Shore I'm gonna put on my
scuba gear and get to the bottom of this
Danika Rome everyone
well
big fans of the show I think you just
lost your job I may be dead now I gotta
tell you Danica so we may not agree on
everything ideologically but or anything
I will say this
needless to say game recognizes game you
won how did you win well I won because
we knocked more doors we made a lot more
phone calls we raised a lot of money and
we proved to that nothing is more
important than we're not to shoot the
treads in your shoes you're talking
about politics did you say wearing the
might mean taking off your shoes and
beating somebody over the head with it
right cause it's some sort of viral
sensation getting people to pay
attention that's how you're supposed to
do it in Trump's America but I just
tried to just say hi I'm Danica and my
number one putt priority is fixing our
2815 route 28 yeah it sucks
okay route 28 is that some sort of
Mexican gang that I'm not afraid of or
what is this route 28 it is in fact a
really really crappy Road that has been
miserable for 30-some odd years and when
I was a kid growing up in the
mid-nineties you know I would be at
school and told 6:30 7:00 o'clock at
night waiting for my mom to come pick me
up because she was battling out on that
road for two hours and in between
Manasses and centreville nothing's
changed so I decided to run to go change
your politicizing roads no yeah but I
thought I thought this is about culture
wars this is modern American politics
isn't that what the Democrats want they
want to make this all about identity
politics and culture wars well the
problem is as transgender people we
don't get to fly our unicorns to work
every day
we have so you have unicorns I know that
guilty as charged but we only get to use
them on weekends and
sometimes Thanksgiving but otherwise we
get stuck in traffic to transgender
people also want to make sure that our
kids have a thriving education we want
to make sure that we can actually work
in the same communities that we live in
and so we want to make sure that you
know we don't have 3,700 uninsured
people living in our districts because
you know when they earn less than they
learn at less than $18,000 a year and
they're still uninsured and so you know
back in April when the entire Republican
caucus voted to leave them uninsured I
said that was wrong and now we're gonna
go fix it when you put that in a tweet
if you can boil that thing down and
maybe I had some crazy video where
somebody gets hurt and now I'm listening
daddy gives I I had an issue with you
all right you wanna it was a big win and
you were asked the night of your win to
respond to your opponent and you had a
chance to slam-dunk him and what you
said was starting next year delegate
Marshall will be one of my constituents
and I'm not going to attack one of my
constituents what are you are you not
even thinking about re-election at that
point where is the long game you
slam-dunk him you make him you make him
smell the dirt that you've stopped and
then you move forward well the bottom
line is the people of the 13th district
didn't elect me to be rude they elected
me to fix route 28 they elected me to
fight Dominion energies power tower
proposal and gain salon Haymarket they
elected me to you know ensure 3700
uninsured people and they you know they
voted for me so that we could actually
make some damn progress and our
Commonwealth as opposed to you know
singling out and stigmatizing the very
people we were elected to serve and I
really don't care what your party
identification is to me it doesn't
matter what you look like where he comes
from how you worship who you love or
yeah how you rock that's how do you rock
how do I rock I'll rock with old-school
thrash metal my son
old-school Thresh is there a new school
through actually actually there is noise
yeah
the noise kind of had to go really
underground for a while but you know
miss boy brought it back who brought it
back municipal waste municipal waste
yeah are you talking politics or another
name of a thrashman doesn't matter
though this is I got to get into thrash
metal it sounds like you do
look we agree on something yeah it is
overdue I'm more of a garage rock guy
which is like I sit in my garage and you
have to love we both agree we do have a
little beef with the New York Times they
called you boring um I don't know at
what point in American culture
a transgender metalhead journalist
stepmom yogini vegetarian became boring
but guilty as charged because when you
just want to fix your roads you want to
make you know take care of water
infrastructure to replace you know
Kastigar and water pipes with ductile
iron pipes so they stop breaking and
then you go home to your partner and
your stepdaughter you and say hey how
was your day as opposed to you know
scandals then I guess yeah it's boring
yeah it's boring Danika tell me
something I already know um something
that you already know is I am the
reigning 1996 All Saints Catholic school
in the NASA's sixth grade Geography Bee
champion
what state is this what state is this
that is the Lower Peninsula of Michigan
you're good you're good
Virginia state delegate elect Danica
Rome everyone the opposition of the time
the fight continues good you hit down
here with a real truth lies you want to
help me defeat the globalists and stay
on the inside click and subscribe
and help me defeat them because
following me on my youtube channel makes
you a leader it tracks trust me